hahaha
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right everybody video Time video
time
anybody seen this video oh no not let me
know
like I said oh no dude the pride of
Japan I like dogs oh
oh is this a guy yeah a suit Jazzy boy
this dog is moving funny dude that
fool's Talons are crazy I want this
music to get us
that's a guy in a suit look how cute it
is though this is like a furry thing oh
is this a furry thing he's gonna [__] in
a box isn't he does this Fool's face is
weird
it's a fake dog what do you mean it's a
fake dog look at it dude no dog moves
like it's a it's an AI dog no I mean uh
it's a robot dog kind of cute right if
it's a robot dog it's cute if it's a guy
in a suit creepy why what's a guy in a
suit that's perfect why can't both be
cute why is that dog five six you don't
want to rub its belly huh you don't want
to rub its belly I don't know if it's a
guy because I'm rubbing a guy's belly I
don't want a rub a guy by the way that
was two f-bombs in the first minute guys
we're killing it sorry
me too pour me too that's probably me it
was probably me oh my God [__] sucker
We're not gonna make it sweat it out let
it out please help us monetize this
video somehow help okay so uh this this
has been that video has been going viral
around uh on the interwebs uh it is
literally a over ten thousand dollar
hyper realistic dog costume that a
Japanese dude a bespoke dog pride of
Japan had made for him 10 G's and it's
because he's always just truly want to
live out his dream and become a dog and
we gotta get better dreams you guys he
does this in a way where he's also too
embarrassed to tell his actual friends
good he should be he should be it's
called Shame he should be dude it's
called bullying we'll teach you to be
more societally palatable when I grow up
I want to be a dog just here's the thing
you could be a dog if you want to be a
dog that's fine just don't tell anybody
about it exactly I would argue that I
would argue that bullying causes this
[__] in Japan because there's so much
bullying there that then they end up
doing queer they double down but that's
kind of that's so different than like if
this was in America they would be like
I'm a dog you must now call me a dog
that's the entitlement they got to go to
the DMV and have a dog and I should go
I should get for this
the pronouns are good boy
you're a good girl
dude that's so different that he's like
I couldn't tell anybody wow weird yeah
you shouldn't so so it actually is kind
of like one of the words that are used
to describe such a costume disturbing
escapism weird
that's like what they say about yeah if
you like playing video games for
freaking 24 dude play we play Nintendogs
yeah I played the dead dogs
followed with everybody saying freak is
you think that's a product of bullying
is that we said I think so why didn't he
severe but I also
I think like so like you think if he got
us
no I think he does that because he gets
his ass kicked yeah
no way
there's no way because I got my ass
kicked a lot so I know if I wear that
I'm gonna get my ass kick some more so
I'll keep my costumes far away from me
dude I accidentally wore a ninja costume
early too early so like the day of like
School Halloween was like the next day
and I showed up with a [__] ninja
costume shut the [__] up yeah the day
before Halloween yeah I get what you're
saying you're saying that he should get
his ass kicked for wearing this but I'm
saying that he's getting his ass kicked
somewhere else so he's escaping through
this oh I see it he's talking about
trauma okay yeah yeah I'm talking about
like the bullying where you know how
like you'd your definition of cool your
definition of cool growing up is
determined by the older kids in the
neighborhood so I feel like hey you
check this out I got this thing and they
go what the hell I just whack yeah
that's why he couldn't tell us
the problem is the older the older kid
in his neighborhood was wearing this
[__] that's the [__] problem he was
that's a bully that's the bag this is uh
the the company that made his bespoke
dog suit uh after that went viral they
now made a wolf suit for anybody who
wants to be a wolf dude just get a dog
wanna be a dog why do you want to be a
dog because that means you want to be a
human if you get a dog do you think
there's this that's a mental thing do
you think that's like a bad like a
disorder yeah it should be in the DSM I
think it's I still standing by he needs
to get it but I mean people here like
get tattooed to the point where they
become lizards or like dragons they need
to get there but that's cool
people here wear Saddles and
[__] can have hoof hands
[Laughter]
doesn't mean okay my point is is like I
don't but this is Hardcore though I
don't have a problem that he's doing it
like yeah you want to be a dog yeah sure
yeah I'm not pissed off I'm pissed off
I'm just saying like why do you gotta
film it and then like put it up on the
internet because I think I think when
Japanese people get into a hobby they go
above and beyond so it the dog suit
looks real everything because if they
did that out here it'll look janky but
why do you have to upload that's the
thing like if you wanna if you want to
pleasure like a private thing pleasure
yourself by yourself personally why did
you have to reach it's like but it went
super viral so that means there's
clearly but you could go viral for bad
things yes dude this is like a guy
called this is like this is like sending
a chicken your jerk off video and it's
like you're welcome yeah it's like you
know you're gonna love my watching me
jerk it but he's jerking it to himself
that video is not getting flat but he's
also trying to find more people like him
and he's probably done that successfully
okay that's cool if you're doing meetups
yeah there's a whole Community yeah do a
meet up
or are they just like I I just want to
know what the end goal is I think the
boys
[Laughter]
I just think when they get into [__]
they get into [__] you know like the
whole low rider Community out there like
oh you don't just get low riders they
become Mexican like they fly the Mexican
flag they have a [__] Taco Stand they
got their socks so high they become
thigh highs like they go they go super
down do you guys think that me and Nick
secretly wish we could be dog people but
we have to lash out like this like like
to cover I'm closeted Yeah Yeah the more
hatred I see it's like I wanna I wanna
rub my boy you wish you were a Cocker I
want someone to feed no not not as my
human form I want somebody to walk me my
Fido form dude if you're a dog what kind
of dog would you be a dachshund a
Rottweiler dude I think I'd be a golden
retriever dude ooh that's a good pick I
think I'm gonna get that Goldies are so
cute though my next dog will probably be
a golden retriever yeah you know what I
would I would be a golden doodle in my
head but I'd look more like a Golden
Retriever and I'd be sad about Golden
Doodle I'd probably get a golden
retriever as a dog yeah I think they're
my next one I just love all in Hawaii
over here I don't know wherever I get a
space that can be permanent what about
like a human that acts like a dog they
just stay in there you know what that
might be a better idea because then I
can I don't have to deal with all the
like the the [__] to get them
wherever I go yeah yeah I just buy them
a [__] economy I'm not gonna walk you
go [__] unzip the back [__] go take a
bathroom you know you get him a service
animal vest yeah how sexual do you think
that is for him extremely all the way 10
10 out of 10. I think he's coming all
inside that suit you know I think uh I
think it's like I think it's like I
think it's a five I think it's part of
it but it's not the main reason why he
wants to do it he wants a belly rub so
he could nut in his pants did you say he
was embarrassed by it was that in the
story or did I make you didn't want to
be uh like uh ostracized by his friends
oh so he put it on the internet really
respect the fact that he's like wanting
to divide it though that's cool like you
don't want to put your worlds together
dude that's not like I'm Bruce Wayne
yeah but he's not vlogging while he's
[__] fighting crime Spider-Man did
Spider-Man did Nikki's childhood friend
is like a dominatrix trick right and and
she has a guy that like she makes work
harder and like clean her house see
that's a good game oh one of those guys
that just [__] has a mask and a ball
and he just stays with the whole time is
like a human slave yeah and she doesn't
she she was telling us she's like yeah I
don't do anything sexual for him
whatsoever I just [__] tell him to
clean all my [__] up I like this I don't
like the verse version of that where
they show up to town hall meetings and
they like talk about all this [__] in
costume yeah yeah that's crazy I don't
like that like change your policies
because of me right but this is cool
like that doesn't hurt it did you see
that one where they were doing this the
lawyer was a cat he had the filter I
couldn't turn it on he couldn't turn it
off yeah I saw that this is the same
thing this just the same thing you can't
turn it up the city council meeting if
they're like yo we don't let dogs like
speak do you think he's like oh
thank you he licks his paws yeah sure
definitely
[__] I just don't like how he was
rolling over on one side and then he's
like check out this other side
dude we get a lot of pressure guy in a
suit
it's impressive a man rolling over is
not impressive would rather a wolf stand
up on his back leg oh my God all right
really dude that really is just like
extreme LARPing and it doesn't [__]
realistic if you if you shoot that you
should be able to get away with murder
yeah yeah yeah
so I saw that [__] six foot wolf yeah
dude it was a werewolf or something six
foot wolf on its hind legs what do you
want that's a direwolf but these guys
are furries right essentially they're
furries because those guys like to do
that too I don't know if they put they
categorize themselves as first I didn't
know what a furry was until like I
watched this one thing it was like a
comic book online and then there was
like these two dogs like playing and
then one had a throbbing boner and then
the other dog started sucking on it but
then the other dog had titties and [__]
like a woman's body yeah and then I was
like what the [__] is this society's too
good because in the beginning the story
started when they were puppies and
they're like they were best friends and
then when they grew up they were like
human body and then she had big ass
titties and she was still a dog they
were going no they're like they're
puppies at first and then they became
older and when they were older he had a
throbbing ass boner because he was going
through dog puberty at indeed red rocket
yeah yeah well there were wolves and
then she started licking his dick and
they started [__] and I was like is
this the furry [__] they were talking
about like and then if you scroll down
it says it in the title of the video you
pornhound
story is just him watching porn and be
like yeah I was watching this thing he's
like then this chick takes her titty out
and I was like whoa that's crazy this
other chick starts sucking on it maybe
he just immediately maximizes the window
so you don't see the title I don't know
how you guys browse porn but then
there's the open page you're using like
an Apple TV no he's like oh my God one
button you click you click you click it
and then you click it and you click it
right and it goes like that it's like
you cook it and then you click oh it's a
four-step process yeah I don't know what
happened I look at pictures you know
what the the difference is that furries
are anthropomorphic and that's a literal
dog yeah I see so it's not a furry yeah
I think furries still have like they
probably look at that like you're not a
partner they're gonna punch me
it's like you look like a combination of
human and and oh out of the way
I'm gonna get in the quad later I wasn't
on a I wasn't on a porn site
foreign
[Laughter]
we had this idea for Joe talking about
porn whatever and Joe's like no no
that's not my brand it's like okay
I can't let this go out okay bro so it's
not like my name I'm a business owner
now at a fine establishment I can't be
tarnishing myself like this yeah I like
when Ken was trying to talk about
furries next to him and Steve was like
Ken I swear to God
laughs